je parlerai pour ma paroisse c'est à
dire pour le calvados bon nous avions
quatre listes qui se sont présentées
et bien alors d'aujourd'hui nous avons
donc un candidat qui se maintient sur
lisieux dont une quadrangulaire pour les
peaux paul deuxième tour avec dix
quelque chose je crois que c'est 10 60
à bayeux donc notre candidat dépasse la
barre des 10% bon bien il était du
conseil municipal qui aura pas de
deuxième tour
pour nous c'est un d'une belle victoire
parce que c'est un c'était un candidat
vraiment nouvellement arrivée il a fait
ce qu'il a pu et je trouve qu obtenir 11
60 c'est un résultat formidable et
giberville giberville où notre candidat
doit tourner autour des 20%
bon il faut dire aussi qu'il était avec
deux listes un forcément donc le maire
est passé du premier coup et puis nous
devons attendre des résultats à caen
apparemment nous flirtons avec les 10%
mais on n'est pas dessus encore un bon
enfin en tout cas je trouve que c'est un
succès oui puis je salue aussi le bon
résultat de notre mon collègue delorme
qui a quand même fait 19 70 à argentan
c'est quand même quelque chose de
formidable
j'ai vu effectivement qu'à perpignan
qu'à béziers nos candidats avaient
obtenu d'excellents résultats béziers je
trouve ces 44 % par la percée historique
oui je pense puisqu'il faut savoir que
les élections municipales ce sont
toujours des élections difficiles pour
nous les élections de proximité
nous avons plutôt un débat qui tourne
autour du national c'est nous n'avons
pas de quasiment 10 du sortant donc
forcément il n'y a pas de prime pour
nous et j'estime que tout le monde sait
que ces personnes ne se retrouver sur
les listes tout le monde a été soliste
du front national en sachant ce qu'elle
faisait
et franchement je trouve que c'est un
faux débat et qui a peut-être d'ailleurs
porter un peu sur nos résultats